je vous parlais d'un trek tm et les rer
que un traître heureux
[Musique]
il ya un traître et je les démasquer
c'est un homme
les greffes ne posez pas de questions
s'apprête à 9 ans il accorde pas alors
le connaissons quoi alors attendez là là
c'est vraiment un succès par la banda le
banc laissant leurs jours ne pas le
révéler mais ça rigolait elle sait pas
écrire avec elecam
je suis allé au marché déjà marché1 s
avec avait aucun sens avait déjà coûté
arrêté au début vos cartes postales que
vous écrivez à vos analyses et hier
allez merci c'est bourré ou ça alors
c'est bien celle des champs qu'elle va
me faire tout un fromage
merci un membre de l'équipe a trahi dpn
touche pas à mon poste
neuf ans d'émission pendant neuf ans à
chérir cette personne avant même à mon
chéri raison personne ce que je suis
offert des chocolats
voilà
oh mammy de chine non c'est pas là
depuis 9 ans paris la mission existe
depuis novembre se veut pas dire que tu
as exactement oui c'est comme une
personne nous a trahis
je vais d'abord montré les images
et vous allez tout de suite reconnaître
cette personne qui est allé travailler
dans notre don à voile a même été
travaillé dans notre dos ce que cette
personne
est allé travailler dans notre dos les
premiers indices
regardez la chanson de la gombe à la
chanson de l'année 2019 sait sur quelle
chaîne se défend non w9 et non merci
améliorons du vécu quotidien
voilà c'est la chanson de l'année des
animes deuxième à 10
[Musique]
deuxième à 10 d'ailleurs je suis même
pas besoin de 0,10 tout ça c'est sans
prévenir on va mettre tout de suite la
vidéo ça peut faire sans prévenir mais
par à coups de fil par sms il en a un
poste à amp tout fait pour cette berçant
plus mais alors pas une émission est
mauvaise une horreur bon alors la
chanson de l'année
j'appellerais plutôt ça la trahison aux
l'analyse regarder et ses personnels
chez vous même d'aller reconnaître cette
personne je vous demander de bien
vouloir vous asseoir sur votre sofa avec
l'aso da
regardez aux locaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne l'accablons pas pour l'instant ne
l'accablons pas en l'instant mal et vous
l'avez reconnu jory de chalais
c'est éric mendes eric mendes digne
descendant de mendès france n'a pas non
rick mendes et le somment de salles de
cette émission région depuis quatre ans
4 ha ouais c'est grave
il était là d'augmentation de l'est
recueilli d'augmentation en augmentation
l'onu eric hall zeiss est la personne la
mieux payée de la boîte avait rêvé par
fonds serait un eric mendes oui il a un
nom à faire le tube de l'été mais il a
fait la trahison de les finales eric sur
la question et ça s vous sur ces images
mais non non non d'abord là la question
est simple est-ce vous sur ces images ou
non ou est-ce peut-être est-ce que vous
avez peut-être un sosie
il ya un bob d'annoncer que en vous
c'est fou ça a priori non mais bon
j'avoue c'est moi oui c'est moi c'est
moi ou
[Musique]
de la table est pas ça reste un ami
c'est plus mon ami
combien j'appelle ça une ordure écouter
ses bras calmez vous eric juste tu sais
je suis ton ami
mais c'était quand alors c'était ce
week-end samedi mais aussi la chance aux
années quand vous avez enregistré pour
tf1 donc vous enregistrez bien entendu
au mois de mai qui sera diffusée en
juillet bien sûr les gens vous voyez là
ils ont 16 ans dont quentin validerait
le non 45
voilà je remplaçais un ami tu sais moi
aussi quand j'ai commencé des flammes en
poche je remplace adam il question et
cette amie en la peluche à beyrouth d'où
il est parti pour un long voyage
oui a les mêmes à savoir si tu es mieux
payé là bas ou ici la question c'est pas
la peine de la position le connais mes
qualités
ne nous mettez pas en mauvaise posture
d'accord oui patron oui ce serait du
coup un très beau geste qui reverse se
cachait une association une association
ou à des chroniqueurs ou ou même à vous
vous le méritez amérique
mais samedi ce samedi samedi donc samedi
est-ce que tu as traversé l'esprit à un
instant de prévenir mais alors même bébé
louise mais je voulais te contacter mais
je pouvais pas parce que j'ai vu ton
niveau
c'est une très bonne réponse j'ai poussé
un mineur et un micro facilement eric je
vais te dire quelque chose vous pouvez
prévenir votre journée je vais te dire
quelque chose tu sais je sais que tu es
un des plus fidèles ici mais tu es viré
et
[Rires]
c'est dans des petites salles ici eric
eric je vais te dire mon chéri tant
qu'il n'y aura pas tes pmp le samedi tu
peux aller travailler bien sûr où tu
veux je te demande juste quelque chose
oui c'est éventuellement si on peut
faire 50 50 sur l'intérêt non c'était
bien ouais c'est top c'est vrai nom
c'est franchement c'était s'écoule
normalement tu dois alors on va la
refaire ses désirs non c'était de la
merde donc au malheur d'arriver à cette
étape c'était sympa très bas je suis
heureux pour toi et je vais te donner
mon numéro comme ça tu pourras aller me
prévenir quand tu partiras de cette
émission à la bourre mais je sais que tu
sera avec nous l'année prochaine
bien sûr cela ferait jaser mais ok voilà
et le moc tard c'est pareil à côté un
quite aux antilles sur un tournoi aussi
co je vais te dire quand on a des amis
comme motard n'a pas besoin d'ennemis